breaking news tonight at 11 police tell
us reports of a shooting at the mgm
tonight are unfounded apparently a glass
door shattered and seemed to have caused
a panic let's get straight out to
madison kimbrough who is out live
tonight madison tell me what you're
seeing
reports of some commotion definitely
happened here on the strip take a look
for yourself as it is really busy around
this area earlier we saw people running
luckily as confirmed like you mentioned
by metro police the commotion was due to
a glass door shattering causing a loud
noise which in turn startled people and
caused them to run things have since
calmed down but as we were walking
towards harmon we saw several people
running it's still unclear where the
glass door was located but police have
said that this incident is near park mgm
of course keep it here on 8 news now for
the latest detail again we did see a lot
of commotion earlier a lot of people
running not knowing what was going on
busy area definitely for sure but it has
since calmed down so there is no need to
worry sending it back to you sasha